[Music]
so there's a new plan in wales that is
going to make hitting your children
punishable by up to five years in jail
and i heard they [ __ ] beat their kids
out there you know what they do worse
than asians
no dude like [ __ ] welsh in like
northern england and all that they're
like asians dude they they're like oh
really they're like walmart white you
know like they're not like oh are they
considered kind of like redneck kind of
british that's like straight up like
they're like irish folks you know like
they're not they got feather dust
they're not no california white is what
i'm trying to say yeah yeah they don't
have names like skylar and then [ __ ]
making me like all organic vegan food
they got some edge to them yeah they're
like learning how to [ __ ] each other up
all day you know got it yeah damn so
that means they can't do that anymore
they're gonna turn california in five
years in jail i think everyone's trying
to be like the californian white it just
feels like reading news whole foods like
because we all grew up getting pretty
[ __ ] up right generally did you get
hit by actually i did not oh wow man you
got loved i probably got hit like
once
once yeah what'd you do and then i don't
remember and then never again i don't
remember were you a good kid i think i
was a good kid i talked to my mom about
this recently too and then i was like
how come i didn't she said she said
you're a really good kid she goes i slap
the memory out of your brain
it's like the men in black thing but
it's just like tasered as a kid i just
didn't even know
like no yeah she didn't hit me she just
pepper sprayed me all the time yeah no i
didn't i didn't really you know what's
crazy is um
like a lot of my family members too that
they got their [ __ ] ass handed to
them like a lot of their parents don't
even remember [ __ ] them up our
parents are all gaslighters though yeah
they're all [ __ ] like abusive
gaslighters dude i think they repress
that memory look i didn't do that they
take a whiff of that themselves like you
spank me like every [ __ ] week shut up
what did you do you remember what you
did that one i don't remember i don't
remember i was probably really really
young what could be so bad that you
would get that one yeah i don't know
what did you punch me what did you guys
do that that made them like beat the
[ __ ] out of you i don't remember i
didn't get beat the [ __ ] out of i i was
forced to kneel on a [ __ ] in the
corner and on carpet it wasn't that bad
but on carpet yeah but facing a wall a
carpet
kneel down on my hands
all these pillows they're tempurpedic
memory for me
but i had to kneel and face a wall and
just do that until whenever my dad was
like all right you can come out now
what's the longest they made you do it i
don't even know i couldn't tell time
because i was just it felt like forever
you were just you were still at peace
time didn't exist that's when can
started doing this he was like no i
didn't even dance that's how he figured
out geometry no but that was my
punishment i didn't get like hit that
much i think i did get hit but it wasn't
it wasn't like i'm [ __ ] bleeding but
my brother got hit like a lot your
brother seems like the type that gets in
trouble your brother's a wild boy he
looks like he deserves it though
[Laughter]
dude i don't know what does he look like
why is that so just look at him do you
just pull him up asian version the asian
version of the dude that sat behind mike
tyson his name's lazy luke
can you have candace brother
yeah there he is yeah we found out this
guy kill him kill him [ __ ] him
that's genghis khan
[Music]
[Laughter]
came up no i gotchu his name's really
lazy lou
l-a-z-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e
look what it looks like your brother's a
gangster lucy um i guess i don't know
it's funny because he looks nothing like
is he at the mermaid caves
he's got a cenote bro that's what it
looks like it's funny because when you
say when you see them together you're
like how are you [ __ ] related he
looks scary as [ __ ] bro it's like the
antithesis of you
yeah yeah yeah basically it's like all
the soft and kind-heartedness went to
him and all the anger and destruction
went to his brother yeah that's crazy
but it's probably like childhood trauma
because for him his life was way harder
than mine you guys not grow up in the
same place we did same house exactly
same parenting everything because your
parents took out their stress on your
brother and when you came out they're
like maybe we did a bad thing that's
interesting no we're only two years
apart who's old only two years older
no i'm younger
but the thing is like we got taught the
same lessons everything but then for
some reason like it maybe it's his
perspective on the world but like he
always felt like everybody's against him
he needed to you know
man up because you never got beat up
yeah maybe because like you just got to
kneel and he was getting his ass no he
we had
the same punishers but then
for some reason he he would misbehave
way more than me so he got you know hit
but yeah are you guys tight we we're
like we don't talk is he protective over
you that's not tight
like if somebody messes with me like
have you ever pulled that card you're
like
my brother's gonna [ __ ] come after
you no and then they they assume he's
probably just like you yeah
[Laughter]
i don't want all of mongolia to [ __ ] me
up no way that's your [ __ ] brother
yeah like when i tell people that oh
yeah this guy's my brother like he's
your brother and then they're always
like oh [ __ ] like they don't mess with
me
yeah
dude
that's crazy that's like looks like a
but you know what i like you you're a
family of hobbies right the funny thing
is like so you know what his brother
looks like right this fool had a chicken
collection so be like hey joe you want
to see my chickens where's chickens
tatted up too no they're pets kid yeah
and he was sitting here and he's all
into [ __ ] chickens so like he had
like this [ __ ] fancy rooster with the
tail that went like this and i didn't
know there were so many different kinds
of chickens and then he gave me a whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] full of eggs like i'm
talking about those costco sized stacks
right
and all and they were all like different
colors i didn't know they came in blue
eggs [ __ ] all kinds of different
colors like it was nuts
happy easter the yolk was orange as hell
too that's some organic [ __ ] so he's
like a gentle giant kind of dude his
person no he's not gentle okay
he likes chicken
opposite of you so his tuts are [ __ ]
this way
just every move you do no he actually
raps oh wait is he good yeah um
have you guys battled did you guys
battle i don't i don't like that type of
music but
but people that do like it you know they
probably really like it but no we don't
battle or anything like that we like
pretty we're like pretty like
separate you know like he lives his life
i live my life but i don't um when we
talk we talk you know you know it's
funny i bet somewhere out there he's
going i'm gonna my brother's gonna come
after you and he's talking about you
and then they're like terrified
yeah did you guys ever fight growing up
uh we fought a lot but like fist fight
yeah we did fist fight before no [ __ ]
way because me and him were always in
disagreement and he would always pick on
me yeah like he would be he would do
[ __ ] like [ __ ] tap my ass and be like
ah you're gay i'm like but you're the
one tapping
i'm so i gotta sit on you
you just got tagged did you tap him
right back and i was like confused so
most of the time that i got bullied by
him
i was mostly confused yeah you're gay
bro
yeah
dude this is but it's not because of
genetics
that's like going up to a dude and like
sucking his dick and being like you're
so over the game
doesn't mean grabbing this dick i'm like
oh you're a molester yeah so you're so
stupid
and i feel molested dude that's
confusing that's a cool thing to learn
about you yeah it's my brother is cool
man
[Laughter]
he's cooler than me
and he protects me yeah
that's cool he's protecting he loves
chickens
man i miss those eggs though man the
blue eggs
you can get that you can get that does
he stop uh
chicken collection no they i think they
got rid of chickens like a long time ago
that was just like back then that was
just a hobby of his uh yeah he was he's
into random yeah
yeah when you get them or obtain these
chickens yeah oh you can go to the store
you can there's like stores in oc where
they sell live chickens like to to sell
as food but you could also buy the baby
chicks and raise them oh
it'd be like going like the chinese
supermarket and buying the fish but
instead of killing it
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] i did that you know
what everybody does
i got some tilapia at the chinese rest
uh chinese uh [ __ ] market pet tilapia
i know i just got tilapia and i was like
you know what i'm gonna do
because it's cheaper when it's small so
i'm just gonna put it in the fish tank
and raise this and it gets bigger and
then i'll eat it when it's bigger right
and i'm so dumb because i'm thinking
about how cheap it is but then when you
buy the fish food and you spend money on
like
raising this [ __ ] takes more
money out of you on top of that he gets
emotionally attached so he doesn't even
eat it i did end up eating it but it was
weird oh that's so does it taste good
crazy like your own what i also wanted
to do too is the tilapia always tastes
like [ __ ] grass depending on like
what kind of pond it was in right so i
was thinking if i put them in like
something like fresh water where it's
not eating algae all day it's gonna have
that cleaner taste so what was it eating
just like little flakes just uh fish
food just regular fish yeah cause then
when you raise it and like in a pond
it's gonna taste like the grass that
it's eating and then i don't like that
taste did it taste better i didn't do it
for long enough he goes it tastes like
history
it still tastes like grass
you are what you eat yeah i could just
eat the fish food then
go straight to the source right i think
the weirdest part is when i killed it i
didn't like slammed its head hard enough
so while i was like cutting it up and
cleaning it it just started wiggling and
[ __ ] and i'm like [ __ ] dude yeah isn't
it illegal to like uh prepare seafood
without killing it
like technically
quick though i don't know why
like they die in like five so when you
boil them life yeah because they're
sentient beings maybe get like five or
six claps and there's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you